circuit 깊이가 너무 깊어서
양자 하드웨어에서 구현하기 어려워요.
일반적으로 계산이 더 잘 되려면
몇 가지가 필요해요.
우선, 레퍼런스 상태와
초기 파라미터 집합을
바닥 상태에 가까운 ansatz 상태를
만들도록 선택해야 해요.
그리고 둘째, 불필요한 파라미터는
피해야 해요.
불필요한 파라미터는 아무 이득 없이
circuit 깊이만 늘리거나,
더 큰 파라미터 공간을
만들어서
고전적 최적화에서
plateau로 이어질 수 있어요.
어떤 파라미터가 필요한지는
문제에 따라 다르고,
신중하게 생각해야 하는
문제예요.
이제 오늘의 주인공인
Hamiltonian이 이 모든 것 속에서
어디에 숨어있는지 얘기해볼게요.
이전 섹션에서 배운 것처럼,
qubit 매핑 후 Hamiltonian은
가중치가 붙은 Pauli 연산자
문자열의 합으로 표현돼요.
결국 우리가 하고 싶은 건
variational form이 만들어낸
ansatz 상태에서 Hamiltonian의
기댓값을 구하는 거예요.
다행히도 양자 역학은
선형적이어서,
그 성질을 이용해서
기댓값을 구할 거예요.
작동 방식은 이래요.
Hamiltonian은 Pauli 연산자의
가중합인데,
선형성 덕분에
합의 기댓값은
각 Pauli 문자열의 기댓값의
합과 같아요.
이게 좋은 이유는, 이미 알고 있듯이
Pauli 기저에서 측정하는 건
표준 측정 기저를 회전시키는 것만큼
간단하거든요.
합으로 표현된 이 거대한 Hamiltonian에서
바로 기댓값을 측정하는 대신,
각 항의 기댓값을 먼저 구하고
마지막에 해당 가중치를 곱해서
합산해요.
그래서 많은 자료들에서
ansatz 뒤에 single qubit 회전만
있는 걸 볼 수 있어요.
이게 바로 circuit을 실행할 때마다
Hamiltonian을 구현하는 방식이에요.
다음 영상에서는,
고전적 최적화 단계에서
무슨 일이 일어나는지 살펴볼 거예요.
거기서 만나요.